Evet
[Müzik]
evet değerli katılımcılar Hepinize iyi
günler diliyorum hoş geldiniz Ben size
bugün konuşmamda bu maskeler ve maskeli
salgın lardan bahsedeceğim Dünü Bugünü
ve yarını dansöz etmeye çalışacağım
biliyorsunuz 2020 yılından beri başından
beri maskeler tüm dünyada en çok
konuşulan tartışılan hatta üzerinde en
çok durulan konuların başında geliyor
yine
hepimizin bildiği gibi zor bir süreçten
geçiyoruz
Sen de buraya gelirken
sahneye çıkana kadar maskeli dedim
Sizler keza şu anda maskeyle devam
ediyorsunuz sanki yaşantımızın bir
parçası haline gelmeye başladı hatta
Geldi Tabii ben bugünkü konuşmamda
diyebilirsiniz ki bana şimdi tam böyle
uzun bir kapanma döneminden sonra tam
yavaş yavaş sosyal aktiviteler
başlamışken bir açılım gelmişken tekrar
komidi komut 19 bize hatırlatacak
mısınız maskelerle bugünkü konuşmamda
bunlara çok fazla değinmeyeceğim asıl
maskenin tarihçesinden sizlere söz
etmeye çalışacağım Ve tabii ki bu
tarihçe-i ile birlikte düğünü biraz
bugünden ve yandan da söz etmeye
çalışacağım maskelerle ilgili olarak Ama
şunu hemen vurgulamak istiyorum ki bi
özellikle solunum yollarıyla bulaşan
hastalıklar ya da salgınlar olduğunda
maske
bu bizim için önemli bir korumada
kullandığımız yöntemlerden bir tanesi
çok özür dilerim acaba slayt ları nasıl
çalıştırabilirim bana yardımcı
olabilirmisiniz ekip arkadaşlarım
Aslında maskenin şöyle bir tarihçesine
baktığımızda
ilk defa
Bu kullanımın tamamen koruma amaçlı
olmadığını görüyoruz
altıncı yüzyılda
Romalılar döneminde veba salgını çok
ciddi bir şekilde hastalığa yol açmakta
ve insanların ölümüne neden olmaktaydı
Dolayısıyla o dönemde bu
ve o dönemde
Ben ölen kişiler tamamen etrafa son
derece vebadan hayatını kaybeden
kişilere etrafa son derece kötü
kokuların yayılmasına neden oluyorlardı
İşte bu kötü kokuları duymamak için otur
ve bağlı hastalarla o dönemde
uğraşan kişiler
al hem altıncı yüzyıldan ama daha çok da
14 17 Yüzyıldan sonra o kokuları
gidermek için maskeleri kullanmaya
başladılar altı yıldaki veba salgınında
Aslında hala günümüzde kullandığımız bir
kelimeden de o dönemden itibaren
Bugünlerde bahsedilmeyen devam
etmektedir çok yaşa kelimesi Aslında
daha o dönemlerden kalan bir kelimedir
çünkü o dönemde vebayı yakalanan
kişilerde en çok görülen yakınmalar dan
bir tanesi Hapşurup ve dolayısıyla
hapşıran kişilerde veba yakalandığı
düşünür ve hayatta kalabilmeleri için
İngilizcesi de God bless you anlamına
gelen ve Türkçe'yi de çok yaşa olarak
çevrilen kelime ta o günlerden günümüze
kadar gelmiştir bir daha sonra 14. ve 17
yüzyılda az önce de söylediğim gibi bir
diğer veba hem Avrupa'yı hem de asla yı
kasıp kavurmaya başladı ve çok sayıda
insan Hatta 14. yüzyılda yaklaşık 200
milyon kişinin vebadan hayatını
kaybettiği görüldü Evet ilk maskelerin
kullanımı ki bakın Burada da
görüyorsunuz korunmadan daha çok bu
vebadan ölen kişilerin ortama yaydıkları
kötü kokulardan korunmak amacıyla Aynen
kuş gagasına benzeyen bir maskenin
kullanılması ydı ki o dönem bu
maskelerinin içerisine tarçın karanfil
ya da güzel koku veren bir ta bu
sitelerde konularak bu kokuların ortaya
çıkması ya da duyulması engellenmeye
çalışılıyordu şimdi maskenin o evrimi ve
ve maske kullanımına giden süreçte neler
oldu biraz hızları onlardan bahsetmek
istiyorum Ruhi Pastör dediğim zaman
hepinizin aklına
biliyosunuz kuduz aşısının bulunan ya da
bulan kişi çok önemli bir buluştur kuduz
aşısının ve Pastör bu Kuduz aşısından
önceki dönemlerde 1867'de şöyle birşey
daha keşfetmişti
insanların vücuduna bir Mikroorganizma
girdiği zaman bu Mikroorganizma Ancak ve
ancak mikroskopla
görülebilen ve hastalığa yol açan bir
Mikroorganizma dır yani o dönemlerde
mikroskopla görülebilen ve insanları
ulaştığında hastalığa yol açabilen bir
Mikroorganizma kavramını ortaya atmıştı
ve yine o yıllarda özellikle çok ünlü
bir cerrah olan Joseph lister
kendisi ameliyatlardan sonra
hastalarda ameliyat yerlerinde Yar
ayarların de çok ciddi yara enfeksiyonu
ya da yarada gelişen bir takım gangren
ların olduğunu gözlemliyor ve buna
çareler arıyordu hemen hemen aynı
dönemde bu Mikroorganizma kavramından
sonra bundan da da
J alarak cesaret alarak veya bu bilgiyi
de ekleyerek Joseph lister bu yara
yerlerindeki bu kangrenin
mikroorganizmalara bağlı olduğunu kabul
etti ve yine kendisi Cerrah olmasına
rağmen ki antisepsi kavramının da
mucididir karbonik asit adı verilen bir
madde ile hem yaraların temizlenmesinde
o dönemde hem de cerrahi aletlerin
temizlenmesine
başlamıştır Bu 11'den sonra
bir süre sonra ise
bu daha yeni cerrahlar yani bundan işte
bir yaklaşık 10-15 sene sonra 1880
yıllarında yeni nesil cerrahlarda
dediler ki evet yara yerine
mikroorganizmaların yerleşmesini Biz
antiseptik takım maddelerle ortadan
kaldıralım Ama bu yeterli değil asıl
bizim yapmamız o yara yerine
mikroorganizmaların yerleşmesine
engellemek onların oraya
tutulmalarını engellemek bakın Bugün
bile çok Önem verdiğimiz ellerin cerrahi
aletlerin Hatta ameliyathane ortamında
bulunan kişilerin nefes alıp vermeleri
sırasında özellikle nefes vermeleri ile
mikroorganizmaların o yara yerine
yapılabileceğini ve bunların da önemli
bir risk faktörü olduğunu söylediler bu
yeni nesil cerrahlar ve dolayısıyla bu
kavram
BM'de daha sonra ya Seda sonra yaklaşık
bir 10-15 sene sonra yine Polonya'da bir
cerrah olan resmi Üniversitesi'nde
juanmi kolit adını verdiğimiz bir
cerrahi ilham kaynağı oluşturdu ve yine
kendisi bir bakteriyolog olan kal
sürükle ile çalışmalara başladık Neydi o
çalışma
insanların ağzından Ve burnundan çıkan
bir takım sekresyonlar buralarda bir
Mikroorganizma barındırabilir mi
yaptıkları çalışma sonrasında gerçekten
bakterilerin ortaya çıktığını ve
bakterilerin ürediğini gördüler ve
Dediler ki biz Eğer ameliyathane
ortamında ağzımıza ve burnumuzu
kapatmazsak buradaki bakteriler bu ya
yerleşip orada enfeksiyona yol açabilir
ve dünyada ilk defa
1897 yılında mikuliç adı verilen bu
Polonyalı genel cerrah kendisinin
tanımladığı
ve gazlı bez maskeyi takmaya başladı ve
böylece ameliyatlarda ilk defa olmak
üzere de cerrahi maskeler kullanılmaya
başlandı ve yine aynı yıl Paris'te de
bir Fransız Cerrah bol Burger adında
Cerrah o da aynı zamanda bu maskeyi
kullanmaya başladılar bakın örnekler o
tarihlere yakın dönemlerde tek parçadan
oluşan gaz maskeler ver ilk zamanlarda
kullanılan ondan yaklaşık bir 20 yıl
sonra yakın kullanılmaya başlanan
cerrahi lerde ameliyatlarda kullanmaya
başlayan maskeleri burada size göstermek
istedim Peki acaba maskeler daha sonraki
süreçlerde sadece ameliyathanelerde mı
kullanıldı acaba toplumda da
kullanılmaya başladı mı
benim hastalarım zaman zaman bana şu
soruyu soruyorlar hocam
acaba bu koyut 19 nedeniyle mi toplumda
mas da kullanılmaya başlandığı tarihte
daha önceki dönemlerde hiç maske
kullanıyormuydu toplumda diye gerçekten
çok güzel ve çok anlamlı soru Aslında
tarihin sayfalarına baktığımızda
bugünden tam 110 yıl öncesine kadar
giden süreçlerde de biz toplumda sadece
ameliyathane değil bu cerrahi
maskelerinin toplumda belirli enfeksiyon
hastalıklarını ya da salgınları önemli
de kullanıldığını Görüyoruz işte
bunlardan bir tanesi 1911 yılında Rusya
ile Çin sınırında bulunan mançurya da
ortaya çıkan yeni bir veba salgınında
karşımıza çıkıyor
hastalığa yakalananların iki gün
içerisinde öldüklerini ve çok sayıda
insanın ölümünün ortaya çıkması üzerine
Çin hükümeti birtakım doktorları
görevlendiriyor o bölgeye ve o bölgedeki
olayın tamamen aydınlatılmasını öğrenmek
üzere bir grup doktoru gönderiyor
bunlardan bir tanesi Çinli Doktor Vur
yente adında iyi bir doktor o dönem
bilinen şeylerden bir tanesi farelerden
insanlara veba pirelerle bulaştı Ama bu
dr.who limon yaptığı araştırmada sadece
bunlarla değil solunum yoluyla da da ve
babanın insanlara ulaşabildiği ortaya
koyuyor bunu anlatmaya çalışıyor ama ne
Çin hükümeti bu anlattığını anlıyor
dinliyor Fikri kabul ediyor ne de halk
ki bu salgından kasıp kavramaları ve
ölmelerine rağmen bu konuyu eğleniyorlar
yine bu doktor Lee'nin bu Söylemlerine
karşı çıkan ya da doğru bulmayan bir
diğer Doktor da o çalışma grubunda
bulunan Fransız gerat Mason ağzında bir
doktor dediğim gibi şimdi doktorun
teröristlerin reddettiği için bu
hastaların bulunduğu yere tamamen önlem
almadan gidip onları ziyaret etme bu tür
ki birkaç gün sonra bu kişinin hayatını
kaybettikten sonra doktor wolverine'in
bu söylediğinin Yani bu virüsün Pardon
bu bakterinin veba mikrobunun tamamen
solunum yoluyla da bulaşabilecek kabul
ediliyor ve insanların maske olan
ilgileri artıyor ve insanlar maske
kullanmaya başlıyorlar o dönemde ve bu
salgın o kullanılan maskelerle kısmen
kontrol altına alınabiliyor bir Peki
zorunlu olarak maskeler ki o dönemde
zorunlu değildir zorunlu maskeler ilk
defa komut 19'da mı kullanıldı Hayır tam
110 yıl önce İspanyol gribi nedeniyle de
zorunlu maske hayatımıza göre
kullanılmaya başlanmıştı Biz 110 yıl
sonra tekrar yeniden Çok ciddi bir
pandemi ile karşı karşıya kaldık ve hala
daha gördüğünüz gibi zorunlu olarak
maskeleri kullanıyoruz Bu salgın 50
milyondan fazla kişinin oy kaybetmesine
yol açtı İspanyol gribi Hatta bazı
kaynaklarda 100 milyona yakın insanın
öldüğü bile söylenmekte ve ilk kez
sağlık çalışanları polisler ve Amerika
Birleşik Devletleri'nde San francisco'da
yaşayanlara maske zorunlu hale getirildi
Aslında bunun adı İspanyol gribi Ama
hastalık İspanya'da başlamadı ilk
Amerika Birleşik Devletleri'nde Hatta
Mexico City adı verilen eyaletlere
askerlerde ortaya çıktı daha sonra
oradan Avrupa'ya Doğru giden askerler
hastalığın Avrupa'da yayılmasına yol
açtılar gribin ve o dönem Bir Dünya
Savaşı sırasında İngilizceyi İspanya
savaşa katılmayan ülkeler dendi
Dolayısıyla basın biraz daha özgürdü
yazılar daha rahat çıka biliyordu Ve o
dönemde Avrupa'ya gittiğimde İspanya'da
da
salgın ya da vakalar görüldüğünden
dolayı ve gazetelerde salgın bu ortaya
çıktığından dolayı grip salgını bunun
için İspanyol gribi salgını adı verildi
ve San Francisco da yaşayanlara maske
zorunluluğunda
takmayanlara on dolara kadar para cezası
veriliyordu Peki ne mi oldu ya gerçekten
Sonuçta San Francisco da yaşayan
kişilerde son derece Az sayıda grip
vakaları görüldü ve son derece az ölüm
vakaları ile karşı karşıya kalındı ve
gerçekten o dönemde grip döneminde aşı
yoktu grip aşısı yoktu ve bu salgın da
bu maske zorunluluğu ve maske kullanımı
sayesinde
hastalığın kontrol altına alınabilmesi
ile bu maskeler hayatımızda o dönemde
çok önemli rol oynadılar bu
mi
Evet bu takıldı herhalde gitmiyor
Ben şimdi son bir kaslar tımar konuşmam
içerisinde 1950'den sonra maskelerinin
etkinliği ve Sandalcı edilmeleri
çalışmalarına çok hızlı verildi ve
maskeyi takan kişilerden çevreye
mikroorganizmaların yayılmasını önlemeye
yönelik çalışmalar yürütüldü o zaman
yapılan çalışmalardaki sonuçları bile
biz bugün hala kullanıyoruz Nedir o
derseniz Eğer bakın Maske ıslandığında
ve nemlendir dininden evlendiğinde
etkinliği ortadan kalkıyor
biliyorsunuz Bu dönemde de hep bunlar
vurgulandı söylendi İşte o dönemde
yapılan çalışmalar Dolayısıyla
Bu çalışmalar bizlere Işık tuttu
1960'lardan sonra da daha güvenli
maskelerinin oluşması için daha standart
maskelerin oluşması için çalışmalar hız
kazandı ha Biz birazdan söyleyeceğim
daha etkili olan ve en 95 adını
verdiğimiz maskelerini Cadı da bu 1972
yıllar içerisinde ortaya çıktı ki bu
yeni tip maskeler cerrahi maskelerden
farklıydı neydi farkı bizim bu şu anda
hepimizin taktığı cerrahi Maske bizim
ağzımızdaki damlacıkların ortam As
açılmasını yayılmasını önlemek amacıyla
daha çok kullandığımız maskeler Halbuki
bazı mikroorganizmalar var ki havada
asılı olarak kalabilmekte ve soğuk soluk
alıp verdiğimiz zaman nefeste biz bu
mikroorganizmaları Ala bilmekteyiz İşte
bunların önlenmesi pek cerrahi
maskelerle mümkün olmamaktadır İşte bu
ihtiyaçtan dolayı en 95 adını verdiğimiz
maskeler icat olmuştur ki bakın virüsler
ki 0.3 mikrometre parti gününe kadar
olabilmekte Hatta daha da bu evrede
virüslerin bile alınmasını engelleyen
bilmektedir günümüze uyarlayarak olursam
şunu söylemek istiyorum günümüzde bu
komut 19 pane misin de Evet damlacıklar
yakın mesafe bulaşma da çok önemli rol
oynuyor hala daha ama ikinci sıklıkta
kapalı ortamda havada asılı kalabilen
virüsün nefes alıp verme ile bulaşması
da son derece bulaştırmadan önemli role
sahip ve o yüzdendir ki zaten sağlık
çalışanlarına sağlık çalıştıkları
ortamlarda en 95 maskeleri belirli bir
süreçten sonra önerilmiştir bakın
cerrahi maskeler günümüzdeki durumuna
bakacak olursak burada hatırlatmak
istediğim hala daha vurgulamak istediğim
önemli noktalar var üç kattan oluşmakta
Bazen çok yanlış kullanımları olabiliyor
renkli olan maskelerinin renkli olan
taraflarını mutlaka dışta tutmak lazım
Çünkü bunun özelliği şu bu dış kısım
dışarıdan bu sıvı sekresyonların orada
tutulmasını engelleyici bir şey tersini
yaptığınız zaman ki bu iç kısım nemli
olan tarafın nemini alan şeydir E bunu
tersine taktığınızda dışarıdan gelecek
damlacıkları Siz maske almış oluyorsunuz
ve hastalığın bulaşması söz konusu
olabilmekte bu maskelerin 3. katının
ortasındaki kısımda filtre edici
özelliğe sahiptir ve günümüzde en
güvenilir olan bu üç katlı olan
maskelerdir ve en 95 maskesinin şematize
edildiğini göstermek istiyorum burada
önemli olan özellik tekrar ediyorum
havada asılı halde kalabilen bir takım
mikroorganizmaların soluk alıp verme ile
girmesini engellemektedir Özellikle de
küçük partiküllerin bunlarda yasa 3
mikrona kadar kuruma mümkündür Ama bunda
03 Mikron boyutunda ki küçük virüsler
zaten bu çatıdır buradaki koruma mümkün
olabilmektedir bir en son olarak ne
söyleyebilirim Bundan sonrası ile ilgili
olarak
bugüne kadar az önce tarihsel gelişimini
söylerken de bahsettiğim pek çok salgın
hastalıklar ortaya çıkmıştır bir hatta
salgın hastalıklar olmadan bile
günümüzdeki Dünya Sağlık Örgütü'nün
verileri her yıl enfeksiyon
hastalıklarından 12 ile 14 milyon insan
her yıl hayatını kaybeden bilmektedir
Hatta Öyle ki günümüzdeki en büyük
tehlikelerden bir tanesi de
antibiyotiklere dirençli
mikroorganizmaların oluşturduğu
enfeksiyonlardır yine Dünya Sağlık
Örgütü 2050 yılına kadar bu hızla
giderse antibiyotiklere dirençli
enfeksiyonlar nedeniyle her sene 10
milyondan daha fazla insanın hayatını
kaybedeceğini söylemektedir ve yine
Sizler biliyorsunuz sonradan sonraya
çıkan pek çok Enfeksiyon hastalıkları
oldu değil mi
lay hastalığı bu ebola sars Ondan sonra
zika her zaman yeni yeni bir takım
mikroorganizmalarla salgınlar her zaman
olabileceğini akıldan çıkartmamak lazım
Dolayısıyla sürpriz bir şey değil Eğer
solunum yoluyla bulaşabilir ve
potansiyeli olan Yeni Bir enfeksiyon
yeni bir salgın söz konusu olacak olursa
bizim maske kullanımımız kaçınılmaz
olarak devam etmek durumunda kalacaktır
ki Aslında bu salgından önce dünyanın
beklediği bir diğer salgın kuş gripleri
ile olacak bir salgın the ve dünya buna
hazırlık yapıyordum aşı çalışmaları kuş
kulüplerine karşı kuş gribine karşı aşı
çalışmaları son derece hızlı bir şekilde
yürütülmüştür fakat kimsenin beklemediği
bir Corona virüs salgını bizleri
bugünlere kadar getirdi sonuç salgın
bitene kadar maskeye Evet hepimiz bu
konuda çok muzları Biz ama devam etmek
durumundayız çok teşekkür ediyorum
abone ol